hey guys I'm Lucy and welcome to the
second part of a reality check double
fill but we're tackling the question
that never seems to go away do violent
video games make us aggressive and since
you asked despite 25 years worth of
research in the area we still don't have
a definitive answer what we do have
however is plenty of debate on the one
side there's charlyk essenes and even
news outlets calling for the restriction
or even outright ban of violent video
games claiming that exposure to them
leads to real-world aggression and
potentially violence on the other there
are those who claim that there can be no
concrete answer because the methodology
used in most studies is fundamentally
flawed there's been many studies that
show a connection between the games and
violence but there's also been a lot of
failed replications of these tests and
at other times there's been research
that simply showed no relationship at
all so why is that why do so many
studies disagree on the topic if there
is or isn't a link surely the research
would be conclusive one way or the other
the truth is a psychological study like
this is incredibly difficult to test for
in the lab so let's start with what
makes a game violent you might see blood
ball or guns and these are all good
answers but when you try to standardize
that and apply it to games for the
purposes of research it's not as simple
for example if we take a look at games
that are frequently used in aggression
studies is shooting a covenant grunt
with a needler really comparable to
pulling someone's head off in mortal
combat is Call of Duty as violent as a
game of doom from graphics to gore
there's a lot of things that games do
differently and you'll find when looking
at videogame research when looking for
games to use as testing materials the
violent games used are simply pulled out
of thin air take for example this study
by Andersen and colleagues which used
for violent games as their testing
material Carmageddon duke nukem mortal
kombat and future cop while yes all have
ESRB ratings of teen and mature is it
the same kind of violence
Carmageddon and future cop both feature
use of an automobile or mech to dole out
violence whereas duke nukem is in first
person
and Mortal Kombat is in third so is it
fair to put all violent video games in
one pot and then call them all out games
are intricate complex and despite the
common notion that all modern
first-person shooters are exactly the
same they're all very different from
each other do we get more invested in a
game if it's in first person or in third
are you more engrossed if it's a
prebuilt character or one that you've
painstakingly crafted yourself there's
tons of things that make using games as
test materials incredibly difficult
that's not to say that some studies
haven't tried to standardize the games
that they use Chris Ferguson and
colleagues compared aggression scores of
participants who played Medal of Honor
I'd assault against those who played
missed three exile they were matched by
popularity graphics year of release and
crucially by first-person perspective
this study showed no relationship
between the violent content and
aggression of the studies where the
games have been matched on various
factors like difficulty or
competitiveness also showed no
relationship and so a lot of studies
don't actually even use video games in
their testing instead they rely on
participants to simply state how many
games they play and for how long but
that in itself raises further issues if
you were a participant in a study about
video games would you line say that you
play fewer hours and you actually do
would you exaggerate the number of hours
you play per week so you'll be a better
participant for the researcher would you
even have a clue
about how many hours you play per week
in the first place which leads us to the
other big problem of violent video game
research just how do you measure
aggression it's a broad term but
basically refers to behavior intended to
harm another who does not wish to be
harmed violence is slightly different in
that its aggression that has extreme
harm as its goal
so all violence is aggression for not
all aggressive act a violent ones
aggressive behavior is kind of tricky to
measure there's various methods like
self reporting using buses aggression
questionnaire there's word completion
studies where those who are aggressive
are more likely to finish the word k-i
with the letters LL whereas those who
aren't feeling as aggressive would
finish with SS there's also another
method known as dispensation of aversive
stimuli after being provoked say by
playing a violent video game you haven't
given the option to give a competitor
either a loud noise blast awesome hot so
the theory being you'll give a longer
louder blast or a bigger hit of sauce
and more aggressive you are yes really
but the problem with some of these
measures of aggression is that they're
simply not standardized in fact some
researchers have shown that depending on
how you analyze the data from these
types of studies you can show the
violent videogames either increase
decrease or have no effect at all on
real-world aggression and in fact these
measures have been outright rejected by
the Supreme Court in the landmark 2011
case Brown versus EMA which attempted to
censor sales of m-rated games in the
state of California the Supreme Court
itself stated these studies have been
rejected by every court to consider them
and with good reason
here's another interesting take from
media researcher Frank Farley who says
that researchers are trying to answer
the Big B which is societal violence
using data from little V which is lab
studies on aggression meaning of the
question do violent video games make us
aggressive is just too complex to answer
just in the lab now there's a lot of
benefits of laboratory experiments like
having control over your variables but
they severely like a world facing
perspective many studies showed that
playing a video game even for a short
amount of time increases both
psychological and physical arousal such
as aggressive behaviors heart rate and
even sweats but we need to look to the
real world to answer the question
discontinued exposure to violent video
games lead to long term aggression well
in the real world there's many many more
factors at play socioeconomic status
family situation peer group being
bullied feelings of isolation depression
and other mental health issues I could
go on but when it comes to human
behavior there's much more at work than
just stimulus and response our actions
are shaped by our previous experience
hormones even how we're feeling that day
if we try to answer a question as big as
do violent video games cause aggressive
behavior then this all needs to be taken
into account we're exposed to violent
media more than ever before and it's
important that we understand the effects
of it but my take is that the research
conducted isn't conclusive and it seems
more interested in answering the
question is this type of media bad then
investigating its intricacies and our
relationship with it
so it works your take be sure to let me
know in the comment section below or
come find me on Twitter I'm at least
James games thanks for watching guys and
I'll see you next time for some more
reality check